gaza's hospitals are overwhelmed with
patients suffering from covid19
the world health organization has warned
that the healthcare system there
may collapse for more than a month
israel's national vaccine campaign
has excluded two and a half million
palestinians
living in the occupied west bank and the
gaza strip
the israeli government said on sunday it
will transfer
5 000 vaccine doses to palestinian
medical workers
this isn't of course the only component
of apartheid in israeli treatment of
palestinians
but it's the latest iteration uh israel
is obligated under international law
under the geneva conventions article 56
requires it
to provide all the materials needed for
public health
and specifically preventive measures to
combat the spread of contagious diseases
and epidemics exactly what we're facing
here israel's vaccine roulette has been
the fastest in the world
more than a quarter of the country's
nine million people have received at
least one days of the fisa job
but the palestinian authority has had to
try to source vaccines itself
as well as use the united nations kovac
scheme for developing countries
human rights watch has called on israel
to carry out its responsibilities and
obligations
under international human rights law
israel's vaccination program has
received international criticism
from the un and world leaders i mean the
israelis have had a very successful
rollout
of the vaccine however
the palestinians have not well if you
look at the
connectivity of the israeli-palestinian
people you can't vaccine one part of
your society and not the other
and think that you're going to be safe
israel's rule
reflects global inequality in access to
vaccines
some countries have ordered more than
they need others
none at all israel has now extended its
vaccination program
to adults aged 35 and older
most palestinians have no way of knowing
when they'll feel
the same sense of relief barbara anger
al jazeera